[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome to
Lecture 15 of 14.13.
Today we're going to talk
about utility from beliefs.
Overall, lectures 15 and 16
are talking about utility
from beliefs and learning.
Well in the previous
lecture, we talked
about attention and
the idea that attention
might be a limited role-- so
you might not have the capacity
to attend as much as we can.
And then thought a little bit
about, what kinds of things
are people paying attention to?
And can it be that
people systematically
attend to the wrong things
and miss important things
in the world?
Today we talk about different
deviations from, perhaps,
optimal belief or optimal
information acquisition, which
is people might derive utility
directly from beliefs that
therefore have potential
incentives to deceive
themselves in certain ways.
Next time, we're
going to talk more
about learning--
sort of deviations
or systematic deviations
from Bayesian learning.
So to summarize
today, we're going
to talk about the
utility from beliefs.
People directly deriving
utility from beliefs,
from what they think
about the world,
about themselves, what's
going to happen in the future
or how smart they are and so on.
On Monday, we're going to talk
about non-Bayesian learning--
this idea that people
essentially have
trouble being visual learners.
Being Bayesian is quite hard.
You may have taken
probability theory and so on
and have learned quite a bit.
But even as a very smart
and educated MIT student,
there will be Bayesian
learning problems
that are way too hard once you
have several variables, lots
of information.
It's just really hard to do
these things in your head.
And people might just
not be very good at it
and then sort of use
heuristics and biases instead.
And then after that, we're
going to talk about projection
and attribution bias,
which essentially,
if people have
trouble predicting
how they might feel in
different states of the world--
if you're hungry, it
might be hard for you
to not think about
being hungry or think
about how it might feel.
But you're not hungry.
If you're sad, it
might be very difficult
for you to understand
how it feels
when you're happy and so on.
And so I should say,
on Thursday and Friday,
tomorrow, you're going to talk
in recitation about Bayesian
learning, which is
sort of like, how
do economists or statisticians
think you should optimally
learn?
What's the Bayesian
benchmark here?
And we're going to talk
then about-- on Monday--
deviations from that.
OK.
So the first big picture
overview is like,
why might people miss
information and fail to learn?
What are potential reasons?
Why might people do that?
And we talked about
true potential issues
already last time.
One is, very broadly,
attention is limited.
That's to say, there's so much
information in the world that
we just cannot
attend to everything.
Right?
And so one specific example
was inattention to taxes.
But you could
think about there's
lots of different
prices in the world.
It's just way too much
information in the world
for you to attend to everything.
And so one example
that we talked about
was inattention to taxes.
It's saying that taxes that are
not included in the sales price
might be easily
missed by people.
And we have this very nice
paper by Chetty et al.
that demonstrated that--
that people essentially
systematically under-estimate
or under-appreciate taxes
that they are exposed to.
People pay more
and more attention
to taxes that are directly
included in the sales price
compared to taxes that are
only added at the counter.
And of course, both of
them you have to pay.
And so you really
should not really
under-appreciate those
taxes, because that's
just expensive for you.
We did not get much into
why are people doing that,
but more like show the
existence of people
seem to be missing those taxes.
Then we talked about reasons why
people might systematically--
and even in the presence of
lots of data in front of them--
not update properly, even if
they are, in fact, Bayesians.
And the reason
might be that they
might have the wrong
theories of the world.
You might think that
certain variables are just
not important for
your well-being
or for any important
things in the world,
and therefore, you
have essentially--
since your attention is
limited, you will only
collect some information.
You only focus your
scarce attention
and memory to what you think is
important things in the world.
And so now if you do that,
you might systematically
miss or not collect data that
would help you essentially
improve your theories
and therefore,
even in the very long run,
even when you get lots of data,
you will not update.
Notice that that's
quite different
from rational inattention.
There is rational inattention
theories would say,
well people's
attention is limited,
but they focus
attention to whatever
is most important for them.
So it can't really be
that they have huge losses
from a lapse of attention,
because if they were, then
they would direct their
attention to something that
could be potentially important.
In contrast, the
"Learning by Noticing"
paper, the theory paper by
Hanna et al. that we discussed,
provides a reason
why people might not
pay attention to stuff that's
really important for them.
And so, again, if
your theory says
that certain aspects or certain
information is not helpful,
you would not pay attention to
those pieces of information.
And if you don't pay attention
to those pieces of information,
you will never update
your own theories
and your own theory
will essentially
persist for a long time,
potentially forever.
We're going to talk now
about two other reasons
for potentially wrong beliefs.
One is anticipatory utility.
This is, essentially,
people like to look forward
to good things in the world.
Suppose you have a vacation
coming up in six months
from now.
You might think about this
positive event going forward.
Essentially, good or bad events
in the future that might happen
and you might derive utility
from those events already now.
Second, there's what people
call ego utility, which
is, people derive utility from
thinking that they are smart,
good-looking, and so on.
So essentially,
they derive utility
from thinking positively
about themselves.
Now for both of those
kinds of pieces of utility,
people now potentially have some
incentives to delude themselves
and to think that
things are perhaps
better than they actually
are, because that
will make them happier.
And so then often there
is, at the end of the day,
there's some trade-off
between having
overly positive or
optimistic beliefs will
make people happier.
They feel good about themselves.
They feel about good things
happening in the future.
But that may come at the cost
of not preparing or taking
wrong actions because people
are sort of overly optimistic.
Right?
So one example would
be people might not
get tested for certain
diseases because they want
to think that they're
the healthy people
and want to be happy
about the future
and look forward to
a positive future.
But of course, if they
were getting tested,
that would help them to take
optimal actions-- potentially
medication or any
other actions reacting
to the potential disease
that they may have.
And for ego utility,
for example,
if you always think that you are
smarter than you actually are,
well that might make you happy.
But at the same time, that
might have come at some cost
and you might not
prepare properly
for some exams or
interviews or other things.
You might just miss
important things that
might hurt you along the way.
And then finally,
the last reason
that we'll talk about next week
is people might simply just
be bad at Bayesian learning.
Then there's no utility from
beliefs or the like involved.
It's just a lot of the
computational issues
that we ask people to
do are just really hard
and people might be bad at that.
And therefore, people use
heuristics and biases.
And then systematically, most
of the time these heuristics
and biases are quite
helpful and help people
making reasonable decisions.
But then often these heuristics
and biases are, in some ways,
systematically wrong.
In some cases-- and
we can then think
about some systematic
errors and perhaps offer
some ways in which
you can improve
people's decision-making
by avoiding these errors.
Now let's talk about
utility from beliefs.
So it's important to understand
that economists typically
define utility functions
over outcomes, such as money,
consumption, health.
Think of these things
as things that people
consume one way or the other,
or things that they can usually
measure at some point.
So you can look at it
like, you have money.
Then if you have money, you will
spend it on consumption goods.
It could be apples and
bananas, of course.
It could be also like haircuts
or other services or health,
for example.
And I can measure whether
you have good or bad health.
Usually we think about
some outcomes that
could be at levels of outcomes.
So essentially, like three
apples or five apples or seven
apples are the arguments
of utility function.
It could be also-- as we
discussed when we talked about
reference-dependent utility--
it could be in part being
deviations from some reference
point or changes over time.
But importantly, here,
the arguments-- or goods
and services, essentially,
are the arguments
of the utility function.
Instead, another
source of utility
could be beliefs
about such outcomes.
So now it's about what might
happen either in the future
or what's happening right now.
And you might directly derive
utility from such beliefs.
Now such utility from beliefs
can be a very powerful source
of utility.
One example, for
example, would be
a high-profile public speech.
Suppose you have to give
a public speech in front
of the entire universe.
Now of course you might
sort of derive utility
directly from that
experience itself.
You might like it a lot.
You might find it
very stressful.
So the 10, 20, 30,
whatever minutes--
however long the speech is--
might give you positive
or negative utility.
But perhaps the utility
of that experience
itself might be or
could be dwarfed
by the stress and anticipation
derived beforehand
from anticipating it.
That is to say, you
might think about it.
You might prepare about it.
You might worry about it.
You might not sleep at night.
So there might be lots of
stress or positive excitement
and anticipation.
Every day-- if you give the
speech sometime in September,
every day until
September you're going
to think about it
positively or negatively.
And you might derive positive
or negative anticipatory utility
from it.
There's another part of
utility that we're not
going to talk about.
It's utility from memories.
So you might afterwards
look back and say, oh,
that was really nice.
And you have a video, and you're
going to enjoy it, and so on.
We're going to not talk about
that, but that's sort of--
backward-looking utility could
be quite important as well.
Now when you think about utility
from beliefs, one way to think
is that this is
all in your head.
But it turns out the
utility from beliefs
can actually even affect
physical outcomes.
In particular,
there's a large body
of research on
placebo effects, which
is defined as a treatment
that can help patients merely
because he or she
believes it will.
That is to say, if you give
people a placebo or a sugar
pill, something that essentially
has no active ingredient,
and tell them that this is,
in fact, an effective drug
for something, that drug
itself, relative to control,
might have treatment effects.
Now that often is the case for
things like pain medication.
Although usually we think pain
medication-- if you give people
placebo pills, compared
to actual pain medication,
these drugs are about a third
as effective as pain medication.
Depends, of course,
on the dosage.
So that's quite powerful,
but then you might say,
well that's only
in people's head,
and maybe people
just say they're
happier or less in pain,
when, in fact, they're not.
There's also some studies
that have actually
found some physical symptoms.
So you give people a
placebo pill and there's
actually physically, in
some measurable ways--
hard measures, not just
self reports-- people
are doing better.
So the placebo effect can
be, in fact, quite powerful.
So when you now think overall
about sources of utility,
it's hard to imagine, in
fact, any source of utility
that's not influenced to
some extent by beliefs.
Often it's about how you
look forward to some things.
It's not just about going
to a restaurant or a date
or having fun with friends.
A lot of it is also just the
anticipation of all of that.
OK.
So now more
specifically, what do we
mean by anticipatory utility?
So many emotions in
particular are intimately
linked, related to what a
person thinks about the future.
And you think about hope, fear,
anxiety, savoring, et cetera--
a lot has to do
with some stuff that
might happen in the
future, some events that
might happen for sure, or
some events that could happen
but we're just worried
about, such as when
people are afraid and
anxious about certain things.
Those are actually things
that might happen, even
with a pretty low probability,
yet people right now
might be for sure quite
anxious or worried or afraid.
Now then how do we
define and think
about anticipatory utility?
Well it's utility derived
now from anticipating
in the future.
So there's stuff
that, in the future,
enters your utility
function directly.
And those events that
will happen in the future
could be consumption,
could be also
services, could be like bad
shocks or any things that
will happen in the future.
Right now, in the
current period,
you're already feeling
good or bad about it.
Or something that will
happen one or several periods
in the future.
And anticipatory utility
is a prime example
of utility from beliefs.
Now how might anticipatory
utility affect behaviors?
You can think about,
broadly speaking,
two classes of implications that
we are going to think about.
There are sort of
other potential effects
that might be there.
So the first one is people, if
they have anticipatory utility,
that might affect the choice
of timing of certain outcomes.
That is to say, if you have the
choice when you can experience
a certain good, you might
want to delay that or not,
depending on your
anticipatory utility.
For example, if I
asked you, would you
like to go on a vacation next
week or six months from now
or six weeks from now?
You might say, in fact,
six months from now
is preferable
because then you'll
have six months to look
forward to that experience
and be really excited about it.
Instead if I say, it's
only next week, well
then, it might be
fun to go next week
and maybe if you're
discounting, you'd
rather it earlier than later.
But then there's not very much
time to look forward to it
and to savor and be excited
about this experience.
So anticipatory utility
might affect the choice
of timing of outcomes.
We're going to talk
about this in a bit.
Second, and perhaps
more consequentially,
anticipatory utility
also may affect
people's beliefs and their
information acquisition.
That is to say, if
there is some things
that I like to look forward
to in life-- for example,
if I think I'm a healthy
person, I'm going to age really
happily, and I'm going
to live until age 90
happily, for a long time,
well then for example,
that anticipatory
utility might then
depend a lot on the beliefs
about my health status.
And now if there were
tests or some information
that I could acquire about
HIV, be it about cancer,
be it about Huntington's
Disease and the like--
it's very serious
potential diseases,
people might under-use or
under-acquire such a type
of information because
they want to maintain
overly positive
beliefs about what's
going to happen in the future.
And that could be
potentially quite important
because if people are not
getting, for example, cancer
screening, well then some
treatments that perhaps could
be done very early
might get delayed,
and that could be
potentially quite costly.
We're going to talk
about this second.
OK.
Let me show you some
motivating evidence
of anticipatory utility.
This is not so much to establish
the existence of such utility
to you as like a very rigorous
test and showing exactly
this is anticipatory utility
and how much of that is there,
but rather to get
you to start thinking
about the patterns of
behavior generated by it.
So George Loewenstein
ingeniously
asked undergrads about their
hypothetical willingness
to pay now to obtain or
avoid certain experiences.
So they asked them
about the willingness
to pay as a function
of the amount of time
until the experience occurs.
So all values are normalized
relative to students'
willingness to pay to obtain
the experience right away.
So you ask people
about, like, how much
are you going to pay for right
away and 24 hours from now
and three days from now, and
a year from now, five years,
10 years from now?
And then the willingness
to pay right now
is 1 by definition and
everything is relative to that.
What are the experiences
that you ask people about?
There's sort of both pleasant
and unpleasant experiences.
One of them is
receiving monetary gain
or avoiding monetary losses.
There's obtaining
a kiss from a movie
star of the student's choice.
And there is avoiding a
non-lethal but very painful
electric shock.
And now you can think
about why Loewenstein
asked about hypothetical
willingness to pay,
because implementing that would
be pretty tough to actually do.
Now when you think about
these types of experiences,
you can think of
it about like, what
would your hypothetical
willingness to pay be?
And how would that look like
as a function of the timing?
Would it go up or would
it go down over time?
And there's going to
be two forces at play.
There's going to be
discounting at play.
And there's going to be
anticipatory utility at play.
We talked about
discounting already
a lot, which is,
people like to have
positive stuff in the present--
or rather in the present
than in the future.
People like to push negative
stuff away to the future.
So if bad stuff is going to
happen, like an electric shock,
you'd rather have
that 10 years from now
rather than right away.
So then the question now is,
how does anticipatory utility
affect those kinds of choices?
And I already gave you some of
the situation to start with,
which is like, if you had a
vacation that you potentially
can experience, would you
rather have this right now?
Would you rather have
it in a week from now,
six months from now,
or 10 years from now?
Well that depends on your
anticipatory utility.
You might prefer to have
it in six months from now
because that allows
you to look forward
to it for quite a long time.
You might not want to
have it 10 years from now.
That might be good
from the perspective
of anticipatory utility, but
it's really, really far away
and you'd rather have things in
the present than in the future.
So maybe if you take
together anticipatory utility
and discounting, you'd rather
have it in an immediate amount
of time from now, which
gives you the sort of a form
of an inverse U-shape
of valuations over time,
or valuations as a
function of when--
right now of a
function of what's
going to happen in the future.
Let me show you what I mean.
So when you look at
Loewenstein's examples--
in particular, the
kiss of the movie star
is an example of
an inverse U, where
this is a pleasant experience.
And what seems to be the
case is that some people
prefer that experience to happen
in three hours, 24 hours, three
days, and one year from now,
compared to immediately.
You see the values
here are always
higher than 1, which is sort of
what things are normalized to.
So let me back up for a second.
What does this graph show?
It shows the time delay on the
x-axis, which is immediately,
three hours, 24 hours, three
days, one year, 10 years
from now on the x-axis.
That's when the actual
experience is happening.
And on the y-axis
is the proportion
of the current value.
And it's normalized to 1, so
the valuation immediately is 1.
Notice that these are
willingness to pay
to receive the experience or
willingness to pay to avoid it.
So everything is positive.
Now for the kiss now,
we see that the delay
of three days from now seems
to have the highest valuation.
So people like to
delay this for a bit.
Notice that discounting would
not generate you this pattern.
Discounting would
say, you want it
right away because you
really enjoy this experience.
So anticipatory utility would
say, well three days from now
and even a year from now
it's better, because now you
can savor it, really
look forward to it,
be excited about it
when that's happening.
However, 10 years
from now, people
seem to like less than right
now, presumably because it's
really, really far away.
So A-- I guess
you're discounting
that a lot and the experience
itself gets discounted a lot.
B-- even the
anticipatory utility
might only kick in
nine years from now
because it's really
so far away that it's
hard to think about this
because it's so far away.
And you might even experience
anticipatory utility
nine years from now.
But you might discount that
as well because it's really
far away in the future.
So it seems like people
have some preference
for the present.
There is some
discounting going on.
And there's sort of two
forces at play-- discounting
versus anticipatory utility.
Now in contrast, when you
look at the negative shock,
here it seems to be
that people really
seem to dislike having that
shock in 10 years or one year
from now, compared to
having it right away.
What's going on here?
Well if you have the shock in
one year, 10 years from now,
this is really an
unpleasant thing
that hangs over your head.
So what, instead, people want
is they'd rather sort of get it
over with right away and not
have to think about it too much
overall.
Now and that's, again, sort of
the opposite of discounting.
If you just had discounting,
what you would say
is, well rather
I'm willing to pay
to avoid it if it's right away.
It's really
unpleasant right away.
It's not so bad if
it's 10 years from now.
So what discounting
would say is,
the function should
be going down
as you see it for losing $4.
And why is that?
Well losing $4 seems to
be like, people rather
do that in the future
rather than in the present.
And it's not really a thing
that you think about it.
You don't have a lot
of anticipatory utility
about losing $4 in
10 years from now.
That's not such a
hugely important thing.
However, if you get an electric
shock 10 years from now,
that might be really unpleasant.
So you really don't want to have
that in the year or 10 years
from now, having this hang
over your head for a long time.
So you'd rather
have it right away
to not have to suffer from
any anticipatory utility, even
though from a discounting
perspective, that's actually
sort of worse.
OK.
And so I already said
all of this-- subjects
prefer a kiss from a movie star
three days rather than now.
They also prefer to
have a shock now rather
than in one year or 10 years.
Remember this is willingness
to pay to avoid a situation,
so the willingness to pay
right now for the shock right
now is lower than
the willingness
to pay in one or 10 years.
So the curve is going up.
Now this contradicts
discounting of any kind.
If you think about
any discounting,
positive or negative
discounting--
as in, you might have a
preference for the present
or preference for the future--
you cannot generate
these kinds of patterns.
In particular, a pattern
that's really hard
to generate is a
pattern where you
get sort of these
hump-shaped cases
where, essentially,
for inverse use,
because either you want
something in the present
or really far away
in the future.
But as I said before, if you had
discounting, what you would get
is essentially things are
either increasing or decreasing.
In the time horizon, positive
things, you want right away.
Negative things you'd
rather have in the future.
And this is not at all
with Loewenstein finds.
Now what is the
natural explanation?
People look forward to the kiss.
So they delay to
enjoy anticipation.
And it's very unpleasant
to anticipate the shock,
so they get it
over with quickly.
Now why did Loewenstein
choose the kiss example?
You can think about
this for a second.
Well it is an experience
with a high degree
of savorability-- something
you can think about and look
forward to in the future.
Loewenstein tries to rule
out alternative explanations
based on preparation.
You might sort of say, well
kissing a movie star right away
might not be great because
you want to get ready, shower,
sleep well, and tell all
your friends about it,
and so on, or get some advice on
which movie star to pick and so
on.
So there might be some reason
that preparation might push you
in three days from now.
Similarly, if he had said a
dinner at a restaurant instead,
you might say,
well in a few days'
delay is perfectly
reasonable even
without anticipatory utility.
You might want to make
a time right away.
It might not be a good time.
You want to get a date,
et cetera, for the dinner.
So choosing stuff later
because of preparation
seems totally reasonable.
That's not what Loewenstein
is talking about here.
He really is thinking
about anticipatory utility.
And so he has some
other examples,
but really, you can argue
that really this is not
about preparation,
but part of that
could be preparation as well.
But what you really think
about is going on is,
really, this is about
anticipatory utility.
When you think
about, is preparation
problematic for the electric
shock in particular?
Well the answer is
no, because that
would induce subjects
to prefer it later,
which is not what
Loewenstein finds.
Remember, Loewenstein
finds that people
would like to have the
shock right away, as opposed
to a year or 10 years from now.
And so preparation
would say, well, I
want it in three days and
a year from now instead.
But that's not really
what Loewenstein finds.
So maybe if you're not
happy with the preparation
explanation for the
kiss of the movie star,
preparation will not be
able to explain to you
the electric shock example.
OK.
There's another example.
So Loewenstein has
this funny thing
where he says, well
getting electric shock has
been a little bit
of a weird example.
So let me find something
more realistic.
And then being an academic,
what he comes up with
is cleaning hamster cages.
So he asked subjects
how much they'd
have to be paid to
clean 100 hamster cages.
I've never cleaned any
hamster cages in my life.
I imagine it'd be
quite unpleasant.
So you think about,
what kinds of patterns
do you expect to see?
And what you expect to
see is sort of something
similar to the electric shock.
So people might really
not look forward
to cleaning hamster
cages in a while from now
and would rather
do it right away
to avoid anticipatory utility.
That would be the pattern.
So that willingness
to pay for avoid it
right away or you'd have
to pay them not so much
do it right away,
compared to having
to do it in a while from
now, because the anticipatory
utility makes things worse, as
it did for the electric shock.
And this is what
Loewenstein finds.
If the payment is
now for cleaning
to be performed next week,
it's going to be like $30.
But if the payment
is now for cleaning
to be performed in
a year from now,
the payment has to be higher.
It's $37.
And again, discounting
preparation or the like
would create the opposite--
people would rather
have it in the future
than in the present, which is
not what Loewenstein finds.
Notice, again, these
are willingness to pay
to have to do the experience.
So how much would I have
to pay you to do it?
Now again there's two
forces here at play--
there is discounting
versus anticipation.
Now how do we think
about discounting?
So we talked about
discounting before.
And there are sort
of three steps
to thinking about discounting
that we talked about.
One was, there was
a question like,
what determines a person's
instantaneous utility
at each point in time?
We didn't talk about this very
much during time preference.
We were just saying like,
here's an instantaneous utility
function that determines how
happy you are at each point
in time.
What we talked a
lot about was, how
do people integrate or aggregate
those utilities across time?
So you have some utility
today, tomorrow, two days,
three days from now.
And we then talked
about, how do you
aggregate, how
much weight do you
put on the different periods?
And then we talked
about, what does
the person predict about the
future utility and behavior?
Which is sort of the
question about sophistication
and naivete that we
discussed as well.
So as I said, the
discounting issues
you covered are
about point number 2.
The sophistication
versus naivete issues
are more about point number 3.
And here, people's prediction
about the future utility
and behavior was only
relevant to the extent
that it was helpful
or harmful in helping
people make good decisions.
Right?
So people didn't derive utility
from being sophisticated
or naive directly.
People only derive utility from
their instantaneous utility
function and from depending
on the weight they
put on those different
instantaneous utilities.
But their prediction
affected their choices,
and their choices, in
turn, affected the utility.
But it was never the case
that people's predictions,
their beliefs directly
entered the utility function.
So instead, anticipatory
utility is about point number 1.
It's about the instantaneous
utility function-- what
goes into that, and
perhaps people's beliefs
about the future might do that.
That's what we're
talking about now.
Now notice that things
like social preferences
or reference-dependent
preferences,
those are also about number 1.
Again, time preferences so
far that we talked about
were about items number 2 and 3.
Now what are the interactions
between anticipation
and discounting?
We talked about this already.
So you can distinguish between
pleasant and unpleasant
experiences.
So anticipatory utility
is stronger for events
that are closer in time, right?
Something that's like
10 years from now,
you're not that worried
about right now.
For something that's tomorrow
or in two hours from now,
you might be really
worried about.
Now for pleasant and
savorable experiences,
some delay is optimal to have
a few periods of anticipation.
So think about
each hour, each day
as a period of anticipation.
So you'd rather have three
days than two days than one day
of anticipation
because each day counts
as the day of anticipation,
and you may value each day.
But you don't want it to be too
far away because then there's
also discounting.
You'd rather have things at the
present or close to the present
than in the future.
You don't want stuff to be in
a year or two years from now
because that's really
far away, and then
you discount that
experience very much.
Notice that you
might also discount
the anticipatory utility.
That is to say, suppose you have
only three days of anticipatory
utility of a nice restaurant
or some nice experience.
Only two or three
days before that
experience you're going
to be excited about it.
Well then if that's
in 10 years from now,
you're going to
discount all of that.
And then that's really far away.
And if you really present
bias or just discount a lot,
then you're also
going to discount
the anticipatory utility.
So there's some trade-off for
savorable, pleasant experiences
between discounting and
anticipatory utility,
which might give you this
inverse-U, hump shape power.
Instead or in contrast,
for unpleasant, fearful
experiences, you want to
either do it immediately
to eliminate periods
of anticipation--
so you might just say,
get it out of the way.
I don't want any
anticipatory utility.
And getting it out of the
way essentially minimizes
anticipatory utility because
you get it over with.
Or you might put it off as much
as possible for discounting
reasons and to
weaken anticipation.
That's to say, let's just
do it in 10 years from now.
I might not worry about
it for quite a while.
I might also just discount
any future anticipation.
And for discounting, if
there's stuff in the future,
I'd rather have bad stuff
happen in the future
than in the present
because it essentially
discounts the future.
And it's good for me to
discount bad stuff that's
happening in the future.
So far we talked
about the implications
of anticipatory utility for
the timing of consumption.
Right?
That is to say, when would
you like a certain experience
to happen?
In the immediate present, in
a few days, or further away
in the future?
But we took it as a given
that something might happen
and then the question
was just when.
You could think of some examples
where that might be important.
Perhaps, more important overall
for people's welfare decisions,
and perhaps also for policy is
people's information-gathering
and beliefs.
That is to say, you might get
a situation where anticipatory
or ego utility--
I'm going to show you--
might affect how much
information people gather.
And they might
not be as informed
as they could be
otherwise because
of those anticipatory
utility reasons.
So one question you might
ask yourself is, well,
would an individual in
a non-strategic setting
with no anticipatory
utility ever strictly prefer
to refuse free information?
And it's actually hard to
come up with some situations
where people just would
refuse information if they're
perfectly neoclassical.
You might say, well people
might be overwhelmed.
There's too much
information available.
And you might not be able
to attend to everything.
But in general, I think
the assumption in economics
is, well the information
could be useful for something.
You might not even
know that right now,
but it might turn out
that actually it's
quite interesting information.
And in particular,
usually, the assumption
is there's free disposal.
Right?
If the information is not
useful, just forget about it.
Don't care about it.
Whatever.
Just write it down
somewhere and whatever.
It might be important
in the future.
But really, why bother
whether or not to have it?
It's no problem.
So you would never
refuse it directly.
You might not pay for it
if you think it's useless,
but you would never refuse
to actually get it for free.
In contrast, somebody with
anticipatory feeling cannot
ignore information because that
information affects his or her
emotions.
But if it's something that
some piece of information
makes you really unhappy,
well it's very hard, actually,
to forget about it and ignore
it because once it's out there,
once you've heard it, it's
really that you can't unhear it
and it's very hard to forget.
In particular, it's
hard to forget stuff
that you really care
about, that you're
upset about or anxious about.
And so it's really hard to do.
And so one quite
interesting example
is Dr. House and Thirteen.
Thirteen is one
of his employees.
She's called Thirteen
because I think
he had 25 or something interns.
And I think he fired
almost all of them
except for Thirteen who was
number 13 of these interns.
He never-- at the
beginning, at least--
bothered to learn
people's names.
So he just gave them numbers.
So Thirteen was number 13.
She was an excellent doctor.
It turns out that her
family had a history
of Huntington's disease.
And Thirteen had the prime
example, in the show,
of information avoidance.
She did not want to learn about
whether she had the disease
or not.
And so the Huntington's
Disease is such
that, if your parents have
the disease, your probability
of having the disease
yourself is way higher than
in the general population.
It's about 50% overall if one of
your parents have the disease.
And so then you might think it's
quite valuable to learn about
whether you have disease or
not, for a variety of decisions
that you might make in the
future or that are relevant
for the future, ranging
from when to retire,
how much to exercise,
what education
to get, how much to save,
whether you have children
or not.
And Dr. House was usually
pretty irrational.
And there is
choices or decisions
that he does, was in fact
being very neoclassical here
and saying, you should
get this information
because it would be
very helpful for you.
He, in fact, went
behind her back,
tested her, and sent
her the results.
And but then, Thirteen, for
at least for quite a while,
did not go to look
at these results,
presumably because she wanted
to make herself think that she
will be healthy and sort of
delude herself in some ways
about being a healthy person
and not having this disease,
even though she was not sure.
And so avoiding that
information helps
you do that because
once you're tested,
you're either
positive or negative.
And it's very hard to
ignore that information
once you have taken it.
But before you have
been tested, you
could always sort
of delude yourself
and make yourself think that
you don't have the disease.
Now what is
Huntington's Disease?
Let me be a little
bit more specific.
It's a degenerative
neurological disorder.
It's a very severe and
heartbreaking disease.
Essentially, it
affects the brain.
It sets on around age
40 and really makes
people very dysfunctional.
And life expectancy is
around 60 for somebody
with Huntington's
Disease compared to 80
or even higher for
people who don't
have Huntington's Disease.
People with parents or a parent
with Huntington's Disease
have about a 50% chance of
developing Huntington's Disease
themselves.
Since the 1990s, there's a
genetic blood test available.
And so you can provide at-risk
individuals with certainty
about whether will
develop it so you
know for sure either you will
develop it or you will not.
And those lab tests
cost about $200 to $300,
plus consulting and other costs.
The tests here are often
covered by insurance,
but most tests are
paid out of pocket.
Emily Oster and co-authors
of the paper that
is on the reading
list were arguing
that people were not doing
that partially to keep
the test results private.
Importantly, there's no cure
or nothing that we can actually
do to improve the disease.
So when you think about other
diseases, such as HIV or other
like, usually there,
there's a key motivation
to learn about whether somebody
is positive or negative,
because then they can get
antiretroviral treatment
or the like.
Here that's not the case.
So there's no actual
cure or behaviors
that you could do to
that could mitigate
the course of the disease.
However, there's other
potential behaviors
that you could engage in--
so prepare you better and
deal better with the disease
once it sets on.
So what are these reasons?
Why could such a
test be valuable?
Think about this for a second.
There's a number of
potential reasons
that you might think about.
I've listed a few.
There's a question
about whether or not
you want to have a child.
There's issues about marriage.
Would you like to get
married or find a partner?
Or do you want to
tell your partner?
And so on.
There's questions
about retirement.
When do you want to retire?
For example, if you wanted to
travel a lot after retirement.
Well if the disease
sets on at age 40,
you might want to do
that a lot earlier.
Education-- usually we think
that the returns to education
are high.
So it's good news for
anybody who is studying.
But usually these
returns are accrued
over a long period of time.
You're done with your
education at the age 22 or 25.
You can then start working
from age 25 to age 65
or the like or even longer.
And so that's a long time.
But if instead, you have
Huntington's Disease,
you might only have until
age 40 or 45 or the like.
So the returns to
education are way lower.
You might also do things
like participation
in clinical research.
Perhaps there's some
chance that at some point
there might be a cure.
You maybe want to
contribute to that.
So there's lots of potential
benefits of knowing,
and that test could really be
extremely valuable for you.
And surely the value could
be higher than $200 or $300.
Now what of the
paper by Oster et al?
So Oster et al. observe
a sample of previously
untested at-risk individuals
over the course of 10 years.
Why is it useful to have a
sample of at-risk individuals?
Well because the
base rate, the rate
of people who are
not at risk, who
don't have any parents
with Huntington's Disease,
that rate is quite low.
So not being tested is
not so much a puzzle.
If your chance is like
0.00-something percent,
then it's really not that--
it's quite costly to do.
It's $200, $300, plus
hassle cost and so on.
And there's many
diseases one could have.
Why test for Huntington's?
It's perfectly reasonable
to not test for it.
But here, there are people,
these at-risk people,
their chance is
50% to start with.
So there's a lot to learn from.
You go from 50% to either 0% of
having it or 100% of having it.
So there's huge changes in
your beliefs, potentially.
While if you are a person
who is not at risk,
your chance of getting
it to start with is like
0.00-something percent, with
very high chance you're going
to go to zero from that.
So that's almost no
change at all anyway.
And there's only like
a tiny, tiny chance
that you're actually
positive, in which, of course,
you might want to change
your behavior quite a bit.
But the weight on that
should be quite low
because the probability of a
positive test is really low.
So Oster et al find very low
rates of this genetic testing.
Fewer than 10% of individuals
pursue predictive testing
during the studies, over
this long period of time.
Many individuals get tested
to confirm the disease rather
than actually learning about
whether they have it or not.
You might think, what's really
important is for the reasons
that I mentioned here--
it's generating knowledge.
Right, you want to know,
should you retire early or not?
For that, you want knowledge.
You want to reveal uncertainty.
So if your chance to have
the disease to start with
is 50%, going from 50%
to 0% or 50% to 100%,
that's huge potential
knowledge that's being created.
Once you think the
chances like 99% or 99.9%,
going from 99% to 100%, you
actually don't learn that much.
And you shouldn't change
your behavior very much
from confirming that
you have the disease.
Similarly, actually,
there's similar evidence
in studies on HIV,
breast cancer,
and other types of testing.
People tend to
systematically under-test
even if the chance of having
certain diseases is quite high.
And what's somewhat different
for HIV and cancer--
any cancer, particularly
breast cancer testing,
there's at least some hope
that if a disease gets
detected early,
one can potentially
do something about it.
There's some recent
controversies or discussions
on like, is cancer
testing actually helpful?
And are we over-testing in the
sense, is the test actually
helpful in detecting
potential diseases?
But surely for HIV, it
would be quite valuable
if you knew early on
whether you have a disease
or not because then
you could essentially
take ARV, antiretroviral
treatment, to help you.
Now let me show you first
who's getting tested.
So what you see on this graph
is on the x-axis investigator
evaluation of symptoms
at the last visit.
So on the left, these are
people who are normal,
who don't show any symptoms.
On the right, people
have like certain signs
of Huntington's Disease.
And everything else
in between, this
is sort of in the
middle of that.
So further to the right means
people have more symptoms.
In particular, to
the very right,
these are people have
like certain symptoms
of Huntington's Disease.
And what we see
is, on the y-axis,
whether people since
their last visit
get tested-- so there are
several visits over time.
And the raw means are what
I wanted you to focus on.
This is the upper
of those two lines.
And what we see is
essentially that testing rates
are very, very low.
The largest are about 5%
in this particular sample.
And that's essentially
increasing in the symptoms
that people have.
So overall that
fraction is high.
And in particular
for people where
you think the value of testing
would be quite high, these are
people who don't necessarily
show any symptoms
and people who have some
symptoms but not very
strong symptoms, you
would think for them
it would be particularly
helpful to get tested
because you could learn a lot.
But instead, those are,
in fact, the people
who almost don't test at all.
The test rates are
something like 1% to 3%.
Now as I said before, for
people with certain signs
of Huntington's Disease,
the objective knowledge
from the test is very low
since there's no cure.
You're almost sure that you
have it anyway, so in a way,
you just really don't
learn very much.
If you have these certain signs
of Huntington's Disease plus
you're genetically predisposed
to have the disease,
the chance of actually having
disease is almost one anyway.
So the test really does not
give you a lot of information.
However, perhaps, it
changes your utilities
from beliefs, which I'm
going to talk about in a bit.
Notice that the
perceived probabilities
of having the disease might
be lower even for people
with certain symptoms.
So what I'm showing you here
is the investigator evaluation.
This is essentially a doctor
or neurologist actually looking
at the symptoms and
looking at, objectively,
what's your chance of
having the disease.
That's different from
what people actually
think they have.
So I guess A-- and
what we learned
here-- is the testing
rates are quite low.
Second, people
systematically under-predict
or are overoptimistic
about not having a disease.
That is what I'm
showing you here,
is a motor score,
which essentially
is an assessment of how
good are your motor skills.
And one unfortunate thing
about Huntington's Disease
is that your motor skills
are deteriorating a lot.
And so a high score
means here, essentially--
if it's bad means essentially
you're not doing well
and you're more likely to
have Huntington's Disease.
And what you see in the
upper limit on the y-axis,
is essentially the
probability-- the objective
and subjective probabilities--
of having the disease.
The upper line here
that you see at the top,
that line is the actual
probability, the estimated
actual probability.
And you see that's essentially
increasing in the motor scores.
So people who have almost
no symptoms overall,
they have essentially a 50%
chance of having the disease.
That's the risk to start with.
But then once people
have more symptoms,
that chance increases.
And once you have a motor
score in the 20s or 30s,
your objective probability
of having the disease
is close to 1.
Now in contrast, the second
line that you see here
in the middle, that is
the people's perceived
probabilities.
Those perceived probabilities
are vastly lower and far less
steep than the
actual probabilities.
You see that people's
perceived probabilities when
they have no symptoms are
still actually reasonably high,
and they're pretty
close to the truth.
They're about 40%, compared to
like something like 50%, 55%.
So that's actually
not that far off,
perhaps because it's very clear.
If you have a parent
who has the disease,
everybody knows essentially,
and particularly in this kind
of study, everybody knows
that the probability of having
the disease is high, and so that
perhaps, people can't really
lie to themselves and
know that the chances are
pretty high if they
have been untested.
But then people seem to
be largely in denial when
it comes to these symptoms.
People have these
symptoms, and when
you have scores of 20 to 30,
their perceived probability
of having the disease is
really only slightly higher.
It's about 50% or the like.
And so the people who
are about here, well
their actual probability
is much higher.
And people don't seem to
update information that's
really unfavorable
toward them in terms
of anticipatory utility
because they seem
to be feeling bad about it.
Notice that there's actually
a significant share of people
who persist and really
thinks about our reports
saying that there's no
chance of having the disease.
So there are some people who
have a motor score of 20 to 30,
and 10% to 20% of
people here seem to say,
I have a 0 chance of
Huntington's Disease, which
really seems to be unfortunately
delusional in some ways.
But really, these might be
people who really just do not
want to think about
it and are just
really worried and anxious.
And they'd rather rule
out that possibility
of being sick for themselves.
Now one important
question then is,
well do individuals
adjust their behaviors?
Right?
So far, we talked about,
are people getting tested?
And the answer is largely no.
Second, what are people's
beliefs about the disease?
And people seem to essentially
be overly optimistic.
Now there's a question,
well, does that
translate into their behaviors?
And now this is another
little bit complicated graph.
But essentially what
the figure shows
is coefficients relative
to those tested negative
for Huntington's Disease.
Let's focus on the black
graphs to start with.
These are people who are certain
to have the disease, compared
to people who are
tested negative.
So what we're comparing
here is people
who tested positive compared
to people who tested negative.
And so the coefficients,
if they're positive,
essentially means
that people are
more likely to
get divorced, more
likely to retire, more likely to
change their finances recently
in their preparation.
They're also more
likely to be pregnant.
So they change,
essentially, their behavior
relative to being negative.
So this is essentially
just comparing
positive and negative people.
I should have said
already, this is a type
of setting where experiments are
pretty difficult and ethically
difficult to do, because if
people really derive utility
from information, providing
people with information
could really make
them worse off.
It's quite different from other
sort of experiments involving
information [AUDIO OUT]
wrong beliefs
or sort of biased information
about certain outcomes.
Usually there, you
would say, well let's
provide them with
good information.
Maybe they improve
their behavior.
So there if you provide people
with correct information,
you could only make
people better off.
Here, however, since
people derive utility
from this information, telling
them the truth about stuff
that they perhaps
didn't know about
could really make them worse
off and deeply unhappy.
And so one wants to be
very careful with that.
And therefore, there are
not a lot of experiments
in this space, at least for now.
So the study here
that I'm showing you
is essentially
observational data.
And in this case,
comparing people
who have tested
positive, compared
to people who tested negative.
If you look at people who
are just tested recently,
arguably, these
two types of people
are not that
different because when
they made the choice of being
tested, they didn't, of course,
know whether they were
positive or negative.
So that comparison
really shows that people
do adjust their behavior.
So people who have
been tested positive
are more likely to change their
lives in pretty dramatic ways.
For example, people are
more likely to get divorced,
more likely retire, and so on.
People are also more
likely to have a pregnancy.
I think this might
be for women only
or for couples
with their spouse.
And that seems like an
interesting result, in a sense.
That's not what I
would have expected.
Now that could be in part-- so
the authors in the paper itself
say that the sample that's
used to look at pregnancies
is relatively small.
So maybe in some sense one
needs to be a little cautious
in interpreting those results.
It could be that people
try to get pregnant or have
a child when they
know about the disease
because they want to
have a child early on.
There seem to be some
technologies where
people can, in fact, avoid that
their child had the disease.
So you could make sure
that doesn't happen.
And there might be some
couples who might say, well,
even if it's the case
that one of the parents
will die early on, if the person
was like 20 years old or the
like, they might want to have
the child early so they can
spend sufficiently much
time with the child
before the onset of the disease.
But anyway, it seems
to be that people--
the black lines are
relatively clearly above zero.
These are coefficients that
compare essentially the black
versus the group
that's negative,
which is the positive versus
negative tested people.
Now when you look at
the uncertain people,
these are people
who, essentially,
with some probability,
are positive
and with some
probability are negative.
What we would sort of
expect is that those people
are somewhere in
between the positive
and the negative people.
So you would expect that the
gray lines are also positive
perhaps not as big
as the black lines.
Instead, you see essentially--
except for the pregnancy
result, and that doesn't seem
to be significant perhaps
because the sample is small--
the gray lines are essentially
pretty close to zero.
So essentially, people who are
uncertain about the disease
behave very similarly to
people who are tested negative.
So essentially, people
who have not been tested
or who are uncertain
about the disease,
they behave as if they
were tested negatively
and likely because they
essentially delude themselves
in some ways, thinking they are
negative when there's no action
that they need to take.
So that really
shows, or the authors
argue that, essentially
the lack of testing
really changes
people's behavior.
Notice that it's very hard for
us to think about welfare--
are people better or
worse off because of that?
Because of course,
it's a choice to do so.
And you might say,
well, I really
value thinking about
I'm pretty healthy
and life is going to be good.
And that's really
valuable to people.
And they take into account
that changes in their finance
and so on would be valuable,
but they're not doing this
because if they
were doing it, they
would have to acknowledge
to themselves that they are,
potentially at least, sick.
OK.
So how should we think about
these beliefs and behaviors?
Let me summarize
what we have seen.
So many people don't get tested,
despite arguably good reasons
to do so.
People are often overoptimistic
about the probability
of not having the disease,
despite often fairly
clear signs that they have it.
And that really seems to
be very much consistent
with anticipatory utility.
People want to feel
good about themselves
and about the future.
And therefore, they're
not getting tested
and therefore they're
overly optimistic.
Such over-optimism then
translates into behavior.
So people react
less to the signs
of likely having the disease
than they arguably should.
In particular, people
who are not tested,
they look a lot
in their behavior
similar to people who
have been tested negative.
And that's to say, perhaps if
they were tested positively,
they would change
their behavior in ways
that could be useful for
them, at least along the road.
Now what models can
explain such behaviors?
It's important to understand
neoclassical models would not
generate these facts,
because you would say, well,
you should be tested because
that would be useful.
And utility is just not--
there's essentially no
utility from beliefs.
So why would you not get tested?
Let's say, well it's
kind of expensive.
But arguably, the value of
doing so should be quite high.
And the insurance
would also pay for it
if you were not
able to afford it.
Now let me write down or
show you a simple model.
There will be a problem set,
a question on this model
for you to understand
it a little better.
So the model is
extremely simple.
It has two periods.
And the relevant outcomes
occur in Period 2.
In Period 2, the
decision-maker will either
be negative with probability p.
So that positive
person essentially
would be healthy, with probably
p of not having the disease.
And that person will be
positive with probability 1-p.
The instantaneous utilities in
Period 2, how they will feel.
Think about Period 2 as being
everything in the future.
So Period 1 is the
period when you
think about potentially getting
tested, which is right now
or this month or the like.
And Period 2 now
is, say, next year,
everything starting
from all of the future.
Now the instantaneous utility
of this long future period
are u-minus and u-plus.
u-minus is if you're negative
so u-minus is the good case.
And u-plus is if
you're positive.
You sort of think that
u-minus is larger than u-plus.
It's better to be negative
than positive in that disease
or in general.
In Period 1, we're going to
look at, now, people's choices.
We can assume no
discounting whatsoever.
That's just for simplicity.
We also assume,
for now at least,
that nothing can be done
about the person's condition.
So A-- there's no cure.
B-- there's also no
financial or other adjustment
that the person might be
able to take to mitigate
the onset of the disease.
For now we're going
to just rule that out.
This is just about, do you
want to find out or not?
And why or why not?
Now what would I expect
the utility theory to say?
Here what is expected utility?
Well it's very simple.
It's essentially, there's
no anticipatory utility.
Expected utility is just what's
going to happen in the future.
The probability p,
you get u-minus, which
is the person is negative.
With probability 1
minus p, the person
is positive and then
recedes utility u-plus.
Notice again, there's
no discounting.
This is in Period 2.
But then since no
discounting, delta or beta
are essentially just 1.
Now let's add anticipatory
utility to this model.
Notice that this type
of utility can only
depend on the
person's beliefs about
whether she will have the
disease or not, not on what
actually happens.
Right?
So the anticipatory
utility depends
on the probability of
having the disease,
and not on the actual
consequences of the disease.
And since the person in Period
1 has this anticipatory utility,
doesn't know for sure whether
she is going to have it or not,
the anticipatory utility will
only depend on the beliefs,
on the probability p for
perceived probability
p of having the disease.
Now we're going to make
two extreme assumptions
about the formation of beliefs.
Number one is
beliefs are correct,
in the sense that the
decision-maker will always
optimally update their beliefs.
And once you've given the
decision-maker a test,
the person cannot just make up
their beliefs in certain ways.
If the test is positive, the
person knows they're positive.
It's negative, a person
knows that they're negative.
So p is either 1 or 0
once they have the test.
Or p is correct in the sense
that the person knows it's p
and there's no wrong
information or beliefs about it.
Second, the
decision-maker can choose
to manipulate her beliefs.
We're going to start
with one, which
is essentially the assumption
that beliefs are correct.
Let the anticipatory utility
in Period 1 be f of p.
And recall that p is the
probability of being negative.
Now let's assume that, which
is obvious in some ways
and uncontroversial that
u-minus is larger than u-plus.
So essentially, again, remember
u-minus is the probability
of being negative.
So utility is higher
in the second period
if you're negative than
when you're positive.
And then f of p, f
is increasing in p.
That's actually not so obvious
in the sense it's not obvious
that going from a
certain percentage
to a higher one, the
anticipatory utility
always increases.
It's a reasonable
assumption, but one
might be arguing about it.
But for now, we're going
to just assume that f of p
is increasing in p.
Now does the person
want to know her status?
Well let's think about this.
So if she doesn't
find out her status,
her utility is f of p,
which is her probability.
Or without finding
anything else is p.
So f of p is just her
anticipatory utility,
plus the term that
we had before,
which is just the expected
utility in the future in Period
2, which is p times u-minus,
plus 1 minus p, times u-plus.
Now if she finds
out her status, she
might find out that she's
either negative or positive.
If she's negative, that's
with probability p,
her utility is the
anticipatory part.
If she's negative,
she just gets f of 1.
She knows for sure
that she's negative.
So there she is f of 1, plus
u-minus in the second period.
All that, again, is
with probability p.
If she's positive,
her utility is f of 0.
So her probability of
being negative is 0.
And then in the second
period, you have u-plus.
Again, that is
probability 1 minus p.
So now her expected utility,
putting these things together,
is the part here in the back,
which is p times u-minus,
plus 1 minus p, times u-plus.
That's what we
already had above.
That's just the expected
utility of Period 2.
And p times a negative
test, which is f of 1,
plus 1 minus p, a positive
test, which is f of 0.
OK.
And so now, if you
want to figure out,
does she want to get tested?
We just have to
compare 1 versus 2--
or 2 minus 1 if you want, if
that's the value of getting
tested.
Notice that the
expected utility part,
what's going to
happen in the future,
will always be the same.
We have p u-minus,
plus 1 minus p, u-plus.
We have that here as well.
The reason for that is because
we assumed previously that we
cannot change the outcome.
Right?
So that's going to cancel
out if we subtract 2 minus 1.
So what we're going to be
left with is essentially
an expression that
depends on f of p.
p times f of 1, plus
1 minus p, f of 0.
When does she reject
or seek information?
Well she's information-averse
if p times f of 1,
plus 1 minus p, times f of
0 is smaller than f of p.
That's exactly-- if you
thought that's the case,
it's exactly like the
concavity condition.
If f is concave, that's in fact
the definition of concavity.
So if f is steeper
for lower values,
then the person will
be information-averse.
So if the person really dislikes
any suspicion of bad news,
for example, due to
anxiety, there's not
much value-added
certainty, then the person
will not get tested and
not seek information.
In contrast, that
function is convex,
that is to say, if it's
steeper for higher value,
than the person really
likes certainty.
So some suspicion of bad
news is not so painful.
That is to say, so
essentially, when
you think about p starting with
something like 50%, what you
want to compare is going from
50% to 100%, versus some 50%
to 0.
And going from 50% to
100% is more valuable.
It improves your anticipatory
utility more than going
from 50% to 0% is sort of
damaging of p of p-negative.
It's a little
confusing notation.
Then essentially the person
will seek information.
And it's the opposite if
the person really dislikes
any suspicion of bad news.
And there's not much
added value of certainty.
Now that is essentially
just a question of,
what does this f
function look like?
And we're going to try
to figure out or try
to estimate that function.
Notice that it's a very simple
example here, where essentially
the person has to always--
there's no self-delusion
of self-deception.
The person always had
to adhere to the truth.
Now consider instead
the possibility
that the person can
manipulate their beliefs
to make yourself feel better.
Now one question you
might ask yourself as well
in the above
framework, would you
want to hold correct beliefs?
Is there any good reason
to hold correct beliefs?
And the answer is clearly no.
Well there's no instrumental
reason of beliefs.
There's no cure.
You can't really
make anything better.
You can't really adjust
your behavior by assumption
currently.
So why you would you
ever think that you
have to do this if you can
make yourself feel better
by increasing your p?
So if she could believe that
she's HD-negative, for sure she
would get higher utility
for whatever happens later,
which is f of 1 is larger
than f of 0, or f of 1
is larger than any f of p.
Right?
Essentially f of p is maximized.
We assume that it's increasing.
It's maximized that p equals 1.
So really in the model
that I showed you so far,
if you could choose
your beliefs,
there's really no
reason whatsoever
of not choosing f of 1.
When there's a question,
well why might you
not want to choose f 1 anyway?
And of course, the
answer is, well
that's because there might
be instrumental reason.
There might be
actually some action
that you might be able to
take to adjust your beliefs.
So in particular,
incorrect beliefs
can lead to mistaken decisions.
You can essentially
make worse decisions
if you have incorrect beliefs.
So then there's a trade-off.
Right?
There's a trade-off
between, on the one hand,
if you have incorrect beliefs,
if you're overly optimistic,
you feel good about it.
And you're happier than
you would be otherwise
because you get to enjoy
anticipatory utility.
But of course, that
might come at the cost
of making wrong decisions.
So in that trade-off in
general, decision-making
with anticipatory utility,
it's like overoptimism leads
to higher utility than realism.
That is to say that if you're
fully optimizing to start with,
some overoptimism would make you
better off because essentially
you get the value
of overoptimism
and then you're not going to
distort your behavior very
much if you were
optimizing to start with.
So generally you can show that
slight optimism, in many cases,
in fact, an optimal thing to do,
even if it comes at some cost.
And of course,
the intuition here
is that the person wants to
believe that she's healthy,
and it makes her feel better.
So she convinced herself that
that's, in fact, the case.
Now optimal expectations,
essentially, as I said,
trade-off-- anticipatory utility
versus the value of knowledge
for making correct choices.
And then, as I said,
overly positive beliefs
are an economic
important implication
of utility from beliefs.
So once you assume or
think about that there
might be utility from
beliefs, then one corollary is
that people tend to have
overly positive beliefs,
because you explained that
with utility from beliefs--
because really people
have incentives
to be overly
optimistic even if that
comes at the cost of potentially
making worse choices.
Next I'm going to show
you some other evidence
of overly optimistic beliefs.
And then in
particular, we're going
to talk about heuristics and
biases, which is again the idea
that people might be
not good patients,
in the sense that they might
not be good at understanding
probabilities and how to update
probabilities accordingly.
Remember, recitation on
Thursday and on Friday
is going to talk about
Bayesian learning.
So if you want a
refresher on that,
that'll be quite helpful
because on Monday we're
going to talk about deviations
from Bayesian learning.
Thank you very much.